what is one thing that you would have to
have in your Barbie Dream House the
slide that goes from the bedroom to the
pool that was my one request to granted
this entire process I was like the one
thing I wanted she was like sure we can
do that food let's say um sandwiches you
know it's kind of a choke Hazard if
we're getting literal about it you don't
want to really have that in a doll's
house we're little kids playing with it
so something less of a joke Hazard like
a giant pizza so I love in the look at
how Margo watch
es it and is like that one and then it's
like and she's like in it oh my God like
her hair is done her makeup's done I
wouldn't have to take any time it would
just be like boom out the house a tub
that massages you
um that is self-cleaning so like a
Jacuzzi that is self-cleaning because
it's disgusting